berlin september 2017 afg chef ghosn an
trifft zum ersten mal auf seinen
zukünftigen nachfolger roland pofalla
vor zwei jahren zieht ihn opa
malermeister aus weißwasser per
direktmandat in den bundestag ein
es ist der beginn einer steilen karriere
auch dank seines mentors bauland wird
grob anna stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender mittelstand und
handwerk seine themen seine reden
bleiben unauffällig bis zum 8 11
dieses jahres frontalangriff auf die
kanzlerin
ich bedauere dass sie uns nicht verrät
welche herrschafts und zersetzung
strategien sie damals bei der fdj
gelernt hat wie man ein volk mit
agitation
wie man ein volk mit agitation und
propaganda in schach das ist ja
wertvolles wissen dass uns dabei helfen
könnte den riss zu kitten der heute
wieder durch deutschland gehen
wenige wochen später afd parteitag kino
krupp aller inszeniert sich in seiner
bewerbungsrede für die bundesspitze als
bürgerlicher kandidat bürgerliche mitte
erreichen wir mit vernunft nur mit
überzeugenden inhalten werden wir neue
wählerschichten erschließen
dazu braucht ist keine drastische
sprache baulands plan geht auf
[Applaus]
applaus auch von georg r rechtsextremer
landesvorsitzende aus thüringen zusammen
mit rechtsaußen andreas kalbitz aus
brandenburg war er offen für den fdp
mann aus dem osten wir haben als als
flügel eine sehr hohe meinung von tino
keller für uns ist es wichtig dass der
osten etwas besser repräsentiert ist als
neuer vorsitzender soll kruppa neue
wählerschichten ansprechen
in einem internen strategiepapier aus
juli dieses jahres unter dem titel die
afg auf dem weg zur volkspartei setzt
die afg und zukunft darauf sich stärker
in der bürgergesellschaft zu verankern
um dort ihren einfluss geltend zu machen
zum beispiel in sportvereinen und
bürgerinitiativen auch tino cooper
engagiert sich für diverse sportvereine
in seiner heimatregion
so steht es mitte november auf seiner
website etwa für den sv grün-weiß
weißwasser in sachsen um diesen verein
geht es training der ringer mannschaft
integration und vielfalt förderung auch
von behinderten kindern für all das
steht der verein die duh paulig arbeitet
seit jahren ehrenamtlich als
geschäftsführer nachfrage nach kuba
unter förderer steht er würde den sv
grün-weiß weißwasser unterstützen sagt
ihnen das was sagt mir jetzt nichts
weiter guido paul ich will es genauer
wissen und schaut die spendenquittungen
von 2009 10 durch
tut mir leid herrmann ist nichts von
herrn popal nein leider nicht
und wie finden sie das es ist wieder auf
deutsch gesagt fast verarsche am ende
findet sich eine einmalige spende aus
dem jahr 2016 in höhe von 150 euro
inzwischen hat kuba den namen des
vereins von seiner webseite entfernt
schriftlich teilen seine anwälte mit die
bezeichnung förderer sei nicht falsch
schließlich habe ihr mann dann den
verein finanziell und
stützt eine der engsten vertrauten von
dino copala war silvia hennersdorf sie
managte seinen bundestagswahlkampf
görlitz september 2017 als grob anna das
direktmandat gewinnt ist sie an seiner
seite
im mai dieses jahres hat sie der ard den
rücken gekehrt die partei hat sich
radikalisiert und propeller hat den
großen vorteil er hat auch das charisma
dass er für beide seiten glaubhaft wirkt
also für die moderaten wie halt auch für
die etwas radikaleren und er hat aber
kein problem sich von den radikaleren
produzieren zu lassen solange sie ihn
als führungspersonen anerkennen was auch
machen
oppach in sachsen märz 2018 zu diesem
bürgerdialog begleitet lipke hennersdorf
den bundestagsabgeordneten kubala er
stellt seine arbeit im bundestag vor
diskutiert mit bürgern etwa zur
zuwanderung frontal21 ist damals dabei
und da kann man in der tat auch für
einer gewissen umvolkung reden dieses
wort sollte man einfach auch mal
benutzen
laut verfassungsschutz heißt es in einem
gutachten zur afd
der begriff umvolkung wird maßgeblich
von rechtsextremisten genutzt
vergangenen sonntag grub anna nach
seiner wahl im interview beim zdf
ich habe nicht in persona non grata im
per umvolkung gesprochen das will ich
ganz klar dementieren
wenngleich ich natürlich bei bürger
spricht dann auch diese
begrifflichkeiten zu hören bekomme
darauf in diesem fall bei ihnen aufträge
reagieren
also sie haben davon gesprochen ja aber
ich halte die umvolkung ich halte den
begriff umvolkung nicht für rechtsextrem
oder also in diese form halte ich ihn
nicht für rechtsextreme später teilen
seine anwälte mit propeller stehe auf
dem boden des grundgesetzes und erweise
jedwedes nationalsozialistisches
rassistisches fremdenfeindliches und
antisemitisches gedankengut entschieden
zurück ich denke einfach das ist eine
spirale radikaler sprache auf der
europa- und auch etliche andere im
bundestag einfach einfach nimmer raus
kommen weil er ganz genau weiß dass es
sein wählerklientel dass die leute gehen
wählen
in niesky januar 2019 afd kreisparteitag
es geht um die kandidaten für die
landtagswahl
die sächsische zeitung ist vor ort
berichtet kritisch kurz darauf ein brief
von propan an die mitglieder des
kreisverbands propeller schreibt dass
die presse eine spaltung und zersetzung
strategie verfolgt mahnt zur vorsicht im
umgang mit der presse schlägt eine
schwarze liste für unseriöse
pressevertreter vor und ruft zur
mäßigung im ausdruck auf und weiter
hintergrundinformationen über als
journalisten getarnte zersetzung agenten
sind natürlich immer willkommen
versetzung ist ein begriff der
ddr-staatssicherheit um politischen
gegnern zu schaden nachfrage
sie haben e mails geschrieben vor
journalisten zersetzung agenten nennen
warum machen sie das wissen das wir so
nennen die journalisten so wollen sie
mir darauf nicht antworten
später teilten seine anwälte mit
es sei falsch dass krupp anna spitzel
und zersetzung methoden befürworte einer
seiner politischen weggefährten ist
roberto kunert mittlerweile sächsische
landtagsabgeordnete die nokia gemeinsam
vor zwei jahren den bundestags wahlkampf
bestritten das war eine ganz ganz irre
geschichte gewesen
kuna beteiligt sich in der jet gruppe
afg sachsen netzwerk dort werden auch
solche bilder geteilt menschen die am
galgen hängen darunter der titel
islamistisches windspiel diskutiert wird
auch über nationalismus und kriegsschuld
afd man kunert schreibt dieser polnische
nationalismus war auch ursächlich für
den ersten september 1939 polen mit
schuld am angriffskrieg durch
hitlerdeutschland kunert äußert sich
nicht
sein parteifreund group anna teilt mit
es handle sich um keine offizielle
jet-gruppe der afd
er unterstütze die inhalte nicht olaf
opfer kennt gruppe aus dem kreisverband
görlitz er hat der ard den rücken
gekehrt mitglieder hätten ihn wegen
seiner frau unter druck gesetzt wir
müssen die familienverhältnisse von
unserem an poker genauer unter die lupe
nehmen weil er ist mit einer session
zusammen volkers frau ist eine roma aus
tschechien fünf kinder hat das paar für
den einen oder anderen in der afd
offenbar ein problem da hat man das
schon gemerkt dass
was war was nicht passt grob an
us-anwälte teilen mit ihm sei nicht
bekannt dass druck auf volker wegen
seiner tschechischen frau ausgeübt
worden sei dies hätte er nicht geduldet
oder gar unterstützt volcker hatte krupp
anna jedoch eine nachricht geschickt
seinen zerschnittenen mitgliedsausweis
und eine warnung vor radikalen tendenzen
aber was sich da in zittau zusammen
getan hat ist höchst gefährlich da bin
ich raus coopers antwort musst du wissen
kann ich nicht beeinflussen also pala
ist schon ein vertreter der nicht in der
afg wo man wirklich sagen muss es in
wolf im schafspelz baulands erbe eine
bürgerliche fassade für die afd
und es sieht danach aus als ob tino coop
anna dieses erbe fortführen wird
[Musik]